had to move because Rook H5 was a deadly  threat yeah lyric H5 uh so Knight FC but  not B4 check  yeah I know King C6 I just think Rook  um D6 Rook Advocates [ __ ] C4 okay  Rook H5 that's it H5 that's it that's it  on the board  look C5 Checkmate is a set and the other  designs  wins the title becomes uh Fisher random  War Champion amazing performance by  Hikaru and I have to say out of all the  players  what a performance by Hikaru he seemed  solid he seemed good he seemed  knowledgeable and he was playing the  openings just much better than Jan in  many positions I felt  yeah on the other hand then also uh Jan  was putting up some incredible  resistance also inside after the  terrible start to the game yeah he  managed to turn the tables he had  everything in his own